how bad does borscht Olsen need to be
before opposition leaders unite to
remove him just since taking office
Johnson has misled the Queen and
unlawfully shut down Parliament he's
threatening to unleash untold chaos on
the country by crashing Britain out the
EU he has removed a party whip from 21
MPs lost the support of some of his
advisers and his own family he has
abused the power of his office using
dangerously divisive language which his
own MPs have described as inciting
violence Johnson can't be oblivious to
police warnings that the fastest-growing
terror threat is from the far right
he knows this and uses incendiary
language regardless yet the leader of
the Liberal Democrats is playing
politics refusing to support Jeremy
Corbyn as leader of an emergency
government but like it or not
Corbin is the leader of the Opposition
rationally and obviously he should lead
a caretaker government following a vote
of no confidence in the Conservatives
we're running out of time and opposition
leaders must focus stopping No Deal is
imperative and backing Corbin is a
necessary step so many members of the
Labour Party don't want Corbin as a
caretaker p.m. or anybody else so why
you would imagine that all the members
of the Unity Party would want to be
there I mean it's farcical to me and how
can all those parties that you're
talking about form a unique unity
government when there is no unity
between them on Monday and it was it was
a shambles they all decided that they
were gonna they were gonna topple borås
dog and this table drags it that we're
gonna smash the Tories and by the end of
Monday they'll all it had all fractured
and falling apart because they couldn't
decide on any policy they couldn't
decide on who they wanted to lead this
government of unity and you know you
criticize Boris Johnson for his use of
inflammatory language Corbin has a
shadow chancellor who is constantly
talking about having Tories killed about
lynching them about killing them but the
inflammatory louder
here it comes Const he has made
offensive comments about estimate on the
idea that the Labour Labour MPs are not
united around him that's actually not
true and branch Ben Bradshaw he spoke to
his kind he's hardly you know he's been
critical of covering the past these
photo Sky News the other day and he was
saying actually the entire party is
united around the idea you cannot get a
sensible position from Jeremy Corbyn on
the crucial position of brexit he you
say he should lead the caretaker
government most the most recent opinion
poll showed him as the most unpopular
due to the opposition since records
began in that began in 1978 but his
position is as Prime Minister he will be
going ago she ate a new deal then he'll
bring it back into a corner referendum
and which way will he campaign he won't
tell us he won't tell it on the biggest
constitutional issue facing this country
since the wall you can't have a man like
that could he showing no leadership in
fact he's abandoned leadership on this
issue ultimately there is a majority in
parliament against no deal the only the
only opportunity the country has had to
give any sort of say on No Deal the
majority vote for parties who ruled it
out in their manifestos so is the
responsibility of a parliament that
opposes No Deal to stop a No Deal and
the only options remaining are either
the deal or we stay in the EU now if
they can't decide between those between
them we need a referendum that is the
only way forward so who leads that
honestly don't care we have run scared
no can I just say this the Labour Party
have run scared from having an election
why because they never lose because not
only are they losing so they've lost the
let the the polls say they're gonna lose
21 to 23 seats in the northern heartland
and also your party membership is
plummeting Rachel it's public it's got
down 40% 14% in the last 18 months can I
just point out respectfully I mean none
of you wants a caretaker government
that's not what you support because it's
a remaining
your dog and it's not your fight so
obviously I understand the urge to
basically have a free-kick but it's
basically irrelevant what you think what
matters is what the Opposition in
governing Parliament thinks and the idea
the idea that the leader of the
Opposition should not lead the emergency
government is just pointless ealer
Swinson has to say Jeremy Corbyn is not
going into number 10 on the basis of
Liberal Democratic you know one of the
first rules of politics is being able to
count and count votes and whether it is
the twenty one rebel conservatives
whether it's the members of change UK
whether is we're in the leaves but No
Deal is an absolute catastrophe if she
believes that she has an utmost
responsibility to stop
No Deal then she needs to do whatever it
takes to the moment that means
supporting Jeremy Corbyn and that's bear
in mind what this emergency government
gonna do it's going to extend article 50
and then call a general election if the
people supporting that government do not
want it to have a mandate for anything
else than they do not need to give it
recently made that point Jeremy Corbyn
as a temporary Prime Minister given we'd
be a minority as well would not have the
power to do things that perhaps one or
two people might be worried he might it
would be simply to do the job of
bringing some calm to our country and
steering us through to another
referendum which is what I think a
majority of parliamentarians and I think
is inevitable and as I just said another
referendum is the only way forward now
you talked about a general election yeah
the reason why you can't have that as an
option is because what happened
last time as I just explained the
majority vote for parties who ruled out
no deal yet a majority of seats went to
parties that were in favor of No Deal so
if that were to happen again if we use a
general election as a second referendum
but it delivers the exact opposite of
what the majority want that would be a
democratic travesty My dear champ
you are quoting the results of the last
election it was also that the majority
of parties who got the most over 18%
were those who said the brics it must be
delivered in one shape or form shape or
form so if you want to quit quote
manifesto promises I'll bring that one
back to you or we'll be editing your
response and just a quick monthly look I
think the fact you know Joe Swenson must
support that to me Rachel it's almost of
desperation
if she doesn't rate him if she doesn't
back him if she'd have then so be it she
has to be respected in that you have you
can I mean in the most recent two
opinion polls the Labour Party isn't
even in second place leader the
opposition is it's because there's no
respect for him if you want if you
genuinely want to stop this No Deal
breaks it you should agree to a proper
heavyweight being head of that caretaker
government would be somebody like Ken
Clark who probably the Liberal Democrats
could unite around
it's got he's gotten better chance of
becoming a caretaker prime minister in
Corbin because Corbin is seen I'm afraid
as a joke figure particularly because of
his stance on Brixham how how would a
unity government be representative of
the people of this country when in fact
it isn't a unity government it would be
a remainig of a think it should be a
caretaker emergency government that's
why I think it's only job should be to
extend article 15 - Clara general
election I don't think that you can have
I don't think which is why they should
immediately declare Jerry